[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum we've got a great
guest on
uh today's episode thanks everybody for
listening
uh to the show uh it's been a lot of fun
uh i sound like i'm it's the end it's
been a lot of fun
and uh this is it uh no i'm gonna keep
doing this as long as you guys are
listening and if you came here to listen
to dax today i hope you'll at least
subscribe and
if you like the show and you like uh me
interviewing people
then hopefully you'll tune in and
subscribe and uh
you know i'd appreciate you giving the
show another chance uh
what's our handles uh inside of you
podcast on instagram and facebook and at
insideepod on twitter um and then you
can also leave messages
which it takes a while but um
hello at insideepodcast.com
and you can leave messages so um it's
been a crazy week
uh i've been watching that show i told
you the val
right and we're gonna be having a guest
coming up soon uh it's incredible so
tune in because then you'll know a
little something and i
you know my interviews you never really
have to know the person anyway i kind of
put things in layman's terms
and get to know them and but uh
it's uh that show is just you know
have you been watching it uh i started
to because we're gonna talk to that
person soon uh
yes but uh yeah i've only got five
minutes in and it's already i'm already
scared yeah you can kind of tell like i
mean from from our perspective from
outside you can already tell from the
beginning like this is not
good well it's funny you say that
because you know when i first started
watching it i go i could do this i could
have joined this the first episode i'm
like
i could use some more self-esteem i
could use some confidence i could
try to get out of my head it seemed like
it was a healthy thing yeah and then
everything just turns to hell yeah i
mean it goes to hell really quickly
and uh anyway we'll get into that
another time i want to thank everybody
for joining us and a shout out
we had a stage it and uh rob and i
played music we
we actually recorded capitol records
this last week
11 songs i want to thank the boys uh
billy and and uh billy duran and um
moran i said duran billy duran billy
moran and
rob humphries and joel and zach and we
had a great time at capitol records
uh recording our new album recording me
and dancing's new album
but we had to stage it on saturday and
we played live music and everybody came
and showed up and
i want to give a shout out to
the winners from the the stage it before
that we didn't give a shout out to and
that's team rogue flask
and leah and kristen
leah and kristen who are the top bidders
and team rogue flask
thank you guys so much for uh being on
there and supporting uh the music
dak shepard's on today and uh i will say
this um
you know i text him and i said hey
listen we did this interview and then
all this stuff happened with the relapse
thing with the pills
and uh you want to say anything he's
like ah you know i pretty much said
everything you know
in a lot of ways and i and i get that
it's not like but i just want to say as
someone who's known dax for
i mean before i mean just
you know it was before he really was
doing anything he was on um punk'd
and uh you know he had he was i knew him
when he was drinking heavily
and doing a lot of drugs and we both did
some stuff and
uh but you know he couldn't stop
and so fast forward he's got this nice
family
uh he's good dad he's good husband
um we're not perfect we're not fm
perfect i'm the
the example of that the spitting image
of uh
imperfection but uh you know he had a
little relapse which i was surprised i
had to hear about it in the news i
you know i think because he started
talking about it on his show
and um you know it was one of those
things where he had an injury
and then he thought it was okay a friend
gave him some pills and it was this
and then it's sort of perpetuated it's
sort of
uh you know that his dad was dying and
they had a lot of friction a lot of love
for each other but they had nothing in
common and
the only thing that they did have in
common was addiction and so they both
popped a percocet one night and just
stared at the lake
and um you know you do things because
you feel an emptiness or you want to
feel a connection or you want to feel
something
or maybe you don't want to feel
something it the way
that way of looking at it i know about
that
but you know he uh confronted his wife
kristen bell about it and
kristen of course is you know cool [ __ ]
she's like you know what you were [ __ ]
up from the accident you were you know
then your dad
and your dad was dying and you know so
but
let's call someone let's get this going
and um
i think what we do and you know i mean
we're all addicts to some extent right
i believe that i think we're all
addicted to something
um you know i feel like you know i was
just
today's my first day without cigarettes
i'm quitting as of today so
okay yeah yeah i'm trying to get rid of
that but we make excuses
like i'm just gonna do two it's okay
it's because i had the surgery it's
gonna be two
or it's gonna i'm just taking one today
what's the big deal it's not you start
making these excuses for yourself
and uh i just think it's really brave
for for dax to uh
just come out with it and say i'm done
because
if it was so little and you were kind of
doing it throughout maybe he just felt
like he kept lying
to you know he was just not being honest
about it and he he used the word shady
he used the word shady he's like i was
being [ __ ] shady so
you know i gotta say that uh it's very
hard to
say you know this is this is what i was
doing this is
how i feel about myself and being honest
with it so
kudos to you brother for uh stepping up
and
uh i love you and i i'm i'm proud of you
um dax and i have had a pretty crazy
relationship i mean
you know we it's definitely one of those
things where it's love and it's just
you know there's definitely a we really
enjoy each other and there's also been
those moments where we're like
well [ __ ] you man well suck a dick man
well [ __ ] you i don't need this [ __ ]
you know like whoa like you know we've
had a couple moments but
we're honest with each other we kind of
just like say what we have to say and if
one of us don't
we work it out and um
i just want to say i'm i'm happy uh that
he's uh
he confronted his his [ __ ] and i need to
confront my [ __ ] a little more
i i you know i think we all do and uh so
thanks for uh doing that [ __ ] boy
uh we're about to get in this uh let you
know that there's some cool
inside wine glasses on the inside of
your store
uh new wine glasses and new mugs and a
bunch of [ __ ] on there so go to the
inside of you online store
um and patrons thank you so much for
continue
continue continual support
or continuing to support the show just
keep digging
geez man it's been a rough morning but
uh everything else is uh everything's
good
all right uh let's get into dak shepard
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i've never you know i'm gonna be honest
with you i've never heard someone
sound so good or so clear your setup is
really good dax oh you're just saying in
general on the podcast
well yes i've listened and your voice is
it's it's crisp
it's refreshing it's like uh nest tea
you remember the
drink the nest tea what's the immediate
feeling you're having right now because
i'm having an immediate feeling
uh a little um excited
a little anxious but excited well like
i'm immediately going like
oh my god i miss rosenbaum so much every
time i see him i love talking to him
why has it been this long uh which is
the nature of life i don't think
anyone's at fault but i'm just
i'm immediately delighted to be seeing
you i
know i'm going to have fun i can't find
my nicotine which is going to be a big
big ordeal it's funny
that was one of my questions by the way
today still on the nicotine still doing
the nicorette
still doing it oh but i mean i mean it's
way worse than that i've been i've been
dipping for now like
six months i guess just no not that long
because i quit
on new year's for a month or two i don't
know
yeah i'm on it you know i mean i could
lie i could lie and tell you i'm not but
i am
does that mean because you quit smoking
you quit drinking
all that into what oh four it's been a
long time yeah i quit drinking you know
four i quit smoking you know five
so i'm i'm i'm on 15 years of no smokey
uh but but i've been on the nicotine
mints for
uh 13 of those 15 years i was off for a
couple years
entirely and then i found literally i
found four mints in a [ __ ] nightstand
and i told kristen
i'm gonna have i'm gonna have these it's
been two years i'm just gonna have one
tonight
i'm gonna have one tomorrow night and
then of course three days later i was at
a cvs buying like 128 pack
of the lozenges my god do you still
dream of darts
so you know i have zero interest in
smoking thank god
uh if something clicked on the last time
i had quit a bunch of times but
i knew it like something changed when
like i'd see someone really cool
uh uh an actor i like smoking in a movie
and it didn't even appeal to me then i
was like once it hit me like
how absurd you're gonna fill these
fleshy little
membranes full of smoke it's crazy like
you should hope to
only put the purest air in those things
and just to
fill them to the brim with the smoke
all of a sudden it finally occurred to
me how crazy that is
how does it finally occur because for me
it has occurred many times
i know what i'm doing when i'm doing you
know it's not a good thing and
you do it that's part of addiction right
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
going yeah uh whatever consequence
there is on the other side of this my
immediate desire to regulate my emotions
uh supersedes that well this you know
for me it was like
especially in the beginning i thought
well this is post-apocalyptic
this is this is i have every right to
have a cigarette who's going to come in
the end
could be the end i'm gonna have a smoke
yeah well and then ironically it turns
up
heavy nicotine uses is is um preventing
people from getting coveted have you
read those
in the new york times yeah there's a
like disproportionately low
mem number of people with covid that are
smokers and nicotine users
there's something about it that has
reduced its ability to
to anchor itself into your body i just
love how sometimes
the way you speak i'm gonna have myself
a little sip of this
oh what do you gotta look for this is a
green tea ginseng
is that an arizona iced tea yeah it is
they're not a sponsor by the way
goodness good for you what a glass for
me is that bad
i have to imagine look at the cans tell
me how many grams of sugar
i can't times it by however many doses i
can't read it my guys are not that good
can't i have context and i still can't
read it you can't read the side of a can
no i can't read a side of a can is that
so frustrating it is in fact um
what i had to do while you were taking a
dump is i had to uh
go and if i had some questions and i
just i i
had a bigger font what yeah what do you
so great look
here's my list of questions from my last
interview that i just got off of
and i go 15 and then if it's a point i
really can't miss like the name of their
book i pop it up to 18.
hold on everyone what number are you on
first of all
if you see me looking i just have to
make sure it's still recording because
i'm doing this obama and there's a lot
of
ocd thing with the recorder well you
know what happened once i was talking to
someone i was like oh my god that is the
best story holy [ __ ]
can you repeat that amazing story
as if it's the first time you've ever
told it to me and what's funny is that
was the one story they wanted cut
oh yeah it was a good story but i had to
respect it you know it's like you got to
respect
did it involve sex or drugs drugs
yeah it wasn't even a big drug either
isn't it weird i mean i guess
i guess i understand because um i
recognize that i'm abnormally
forthcoming with all my [ __ ] but but
even within that
and recognizing i'm on the far end of
the spectrum
some things people hold on to i just
can't wrap my head around
like what well like drug use
who the [ __ ] cares i i just you know
there'll be people that like don't want
to admit they smoke weed
i'm just confused by it a little bit
yeah i get it's hard
sometimes to because we're so open you
have uh
i think you're definitely one of the
responsible not responsible
i mean you're responsible but you're one
of the reasons
why i think i'm more open i i be i've
become more open i think this podcast
has caused me to be more open
because you start to think i i it's
almost like i have to be honest what am
i talking about if i'm not if i can't be
honest about
everything and so that but you
definitely
you're just the first time you were on
people would always respond like that
was that you're you're
in don't you find that if you if you if
you're not going to be honest about
stuff
they're just roadblocks in interviewing
right because you
you're like oh i could relate to them
right now or i could
you know i could advance this whole
thing but i but i don't want to tell
people i've
done cocaine so now i can't advance it
because of that and it just
they all end up being little roadblocks
along the way i think that's right
because i
i definitely feel when i start opening
up about my anxiety
childhood anything i feel like then
people are like sort of like oh
wow he's it just sort of like makes
things okay burst into flames
absolutely what i don't understand
though is something that you have a gift
for doing it or maybe it's just the
patience to do it which surprises me
because i've seen you impatient
you know okay sure but how do you do
directing so yeah well
well i don't know you you were pretty
solid when you directed you you kept
your cool
the only thing you ever said i'm in a
hurry i guess is what i'm saying i'm
i'm a very frenetic fast-paced yes
but i remember i remember one time we
just had this conversation on set it was
on hit and run
which i i love doing and i think it's a
great movie by the way
i do i really love that i love the part
i love everyone i love everyone in the
movie it was just a lot of fun this
little indie thing and like
you were just you know you're the lead
in it which i should have learned when i
did mine
not to do that that's the hardest thing
ever i don't know how we survived but i
remember you sitting there
like do you trust me what
do you trust me i go yeah then
then what are we talking about just
trust me you're gonna
it's gonna be fine and i remember that
was a perfect pair because we have kind
of the same
fears like we both well i'll speak for
me i have a huge authority
thing just right out of the gates i
cannot stand authority i think it's
because of step dads that you had
stepdads i don't need some
person telling me the game plan i had
enough of that
yeah so yeah right out of the gates
and i had a lot of adults around me and
childhood that had
nefarious plans even if they weren't
evil they just had like self-serving
plans that i was the victim of so
you know forever going forward i just i
i'm a little preoccupied by what's your
real intention
here what's your real motivation what
are you really trying to get
you know right let's cut through all the
fine tape here let's
let's just get to where you want what
are you saying
because you're beating around the bush
here is it you don't trust me
because if it's how you're gonna look on
film if it's how you're gonna
then i want you to trust me i've got
that
and sometimes you need that and
sometimes look i have uh i think the
biggest arguments i've ever gotten in my
life
were authoritative figures you're right
uh directors
not many well and i bet we remember a i
bet we remember different details of
that conversation and then
b i bet we remember different outcomes
of that conversation because
of course you and i are just we're
creating a narrative at all times so
mine's very self-serving
so my memory of that i felt like the
moment where i got you to click in
a little bit was i was like you know do
you want to be in the same movie as
everyone
else because i can tell you like what
movie all these people are in
and i'm trying to get you in the same
movie and i do feel a little bit like
once i took it away from it it's not
what i want i'm not trying to
control you right i'm just we we
established some tone in this movie
and you can either be in in in concert
with that or you can be playing the
trumpet
on your own right you know you pick
yeah and i think it's sometimes you know
as an actor you probably
well he hired me for the he hired me he
knows what i could do i'm just going to
go balls out and try a bunch of things
and but you wanted you wanted
asbestos specificity you wanted and and
by the
way and that's not a word i get out
easily or use
uh but it made sense and sometimes it
doesn't make sense until you
see things until and i you know when you
show me sounds like uh
oh like i don't have to do much like
this is like it's there so i i get it it
was one of those
it was a great conversation i think that
that needs to happen i think uh
but my question really is first of all
you do three hour interviews i know and
it's it's it's
like rogan does that too you guys do it
and maybe i
i for me i just don't have the patience
i can't talk to people more than an hour
sometimes it's an hour and a half
spectrum of add let's say we're all
somewhere on it
zero to ten you're certainly higher on
it than i am yeah
yeah so i wouldn't expect that you you
would be able to just
stay in the zone for three hours yeah
that's hard i think even when you and i
did our live show
um that was great enough at an hour
well it's not that i had enough no i'm
just like i feel like i have an energy
and i bring a sort of energy and i'm
like yeah and i'm just excited i'm
telling this
and then i hit a wall somewhere along
the line yes and again from my point of
view that whole day was so funny because
we
we flew down together and you were being
so funny on the plane
and you were entertaining all these new
people which is exactly what i would do
it's like all these new people to get
approval from
yep and like i'm enjoying it and then
the producer me occasionally
is like above it all going like i don't
know rose and bob's gonna have anything
left for the show tonight yeah this
would be an extraordinary output to do
twice and it's a two-hour flight so i
basically you're gonna do
two two-hour shows and luckily we found
you a hotel room
sent you there to just recoup and
recharge for
the pizza i passed out that flight of
dinner
you did you put on like a real show the
whole flight
yeah and then on the way home you broke
the door down the cockpit was locked
they couldn't open the door you kicked
it down you remember that
didn't didn't jay kick it down oh maybe
it was jay
yeah cause it was his plane did i kick
it i i can't remember i just remember
going thank god the owner of the plane
is here
yeah exactly otherwise you're like well
i hope he doesn't but [ __ ] it that
cockpit door needed to be open well we
started getting a little claustrophobic
yeah i was getting worried i didn't like
it
yeah i didn't feel well i was hiding i
was just like uh-huh yeah sure
uh you know back to that whole thing
about authoritative figures
you know when because you've directed a
lot you know you directed big movies you
directed small movies
episodes of tv parenthood this and that
but like when you're on set now as an
actor
i know you i think well enough that
when someone else is directing if you
don't really like them
like how they're doing this and how
they're moving i know it
probably pisses you off like you get
really upset well
yeah it does and and
i'm aware that i have an oversized
reaction to it
you know what i'm saying like i like to
think i'm self-aware enough to go
a i'm not uniquely victimized by this
whatever problems this director has
certainly every cast member's
experiencing it right
so i have to kind of remind myself like
i'm not uniquely put upon right now i'm
just one of
all these people that have to deal with
the director i try to remember that
and then i go i i have a uniquely
uh strong reaction to to being a part of
a game plan i don't agree with
you know from childhood baggage but i
mean does that alleviate
the the the angst in me not a ton
but but i have learned a little bit to
um
work around it in that i've learned how
to help them know how to talk to me
this is like an adam grant guy adam
grant this genius
uh uh professor who we've interviewed
and not now i'm
like uh he's my religion but at any rate
like you gotta you gotta give people
uh an operator manual for you you can't
assume people know
your childhood and your triggers and all
this [ __ ] so like you do people a real
favor
by giving them the operator's manual on
you so so i i tend to tell the directors
like ahead of time like
you know what would help me is if you
tell me what the scene needs i'll i'll
help you get what the scene needs
but if you if you start micromanaging
what i'm doing i'm going to get
defensive i'm just too insecure
and so let me be a part of helping you
get what you need out of the scene
because because what what i think a lot
of times what happens is these these
arguments between directors and actors
the actor is right
the actor's doing something that would
be truthful in the moment
and and you're not gonna persuade them
or convince them that they're not
but the director has to make the whole
thing work they have to make the whole
movie make sense and a lot of times that
involves not doing something that's
necessarily truthful in the moment
to tell the greater story so the
director's like balancing what would
maybe be
dead truthful in the moment versus what
they have to what the scene has to be to
make the next scene work so
if you let me in on the big project i
can probably i'm more apt to like
do something that i i think feels
fraudulent in the moment to help you get
the big thing for the scene
have you had uh directors where they
don't want to
do that they're like this is the way
it's doing it and you can [ __ ] pout
about it or get pissed about i don't
give a [ __ ]
and have they ever played that card with
you um
yeah i gotta say i'm i'm generally a
mean uh amenable
amenable specificity
specificity um you know obviously it's
it's something you would experience way
more on uh in a movie than on tv
like on tv i'm very sympathetic to those
directors man they come in
everyone knows each other they've known
each other for a couple years and they
got to be the boss
and they're the newbies group and
they're an outsider it's like
i was i said this the other day like it
would be like moving to a new school and
when they introduce you to the class
they tell them
they're you're also the school president
like here's meet dax he just moved here
from milford michigan
right and he's now the school president
everyone's going to hate that [ __ ]
kid
and that is what a tv director's life is
they come in as an outsider and they're
the boss
yeah i mean do you do you feel like
there's certain things that you actually
really care about i try to
do this i try to work as though i care
about this
and i really want to be an integral part
of it and i want to have a say and i
want to have an opinion
and then there's some things i've done
we're like i don't even care i don't
care
do whatever you want to do get me out of
here so i can go home i'll i'll hit my
marks i'll say my lines but i don't
really care
it's not worth me getting upset about
well increasingly
as i've done this longer that i'm of
that opinion most of the time
my my my in fact my agitation with
directors
uh in the last couple years is almost
never about creative
it's it's all about why are we gonna do
it this way it'll take four times as
long and we won't accomplish the thing
any
better than we would if we did it this
way you know that's my frustration
generally
you know what their answer is their
answer is always like well i'm being
creative and i want to do something that
i think is hasn't been seen or that
that's why i'm doing it
if we do it your way it's cookie cutter
and they're not gonna ask me back
so it's out of a place of fear perhaps
yeah i i'm sure it is but you know you
have to kind of assess like
some people want to be away from their
family and i get it
i mean especially right now after two
and a half months in a house with my
family
put me in a 16 hour a day set i'll be
happy as a clam
but in general i want to go home and see
my family and i understand a lot of
people don't want to
right and that's where the that that's
kind of where it gets into a situation
where
there almost appears to be no compromise
because you just
you want to be at work all day and i
don't right
and i don't know how we i don't know how
we solve that so my suggestion is like
there's some actors here that also don't
want to be home
you guys go crazy on the days you're
with them [ __ ] shoot 20 hours
uh you know yeah but for me let's let's
keep it
let's keep it lean mean and you know
taillights seriously you know
by the way i've also found that it's not
like the quality of my acting has gone
down
when i was when i was crazy about acting
and i thought
so much about it and i had to do this
thing and they had to
let me show you what this would work all
that you add up
all those performances with the ones
where i didn't give a [ __ ] i don't think
there's a difference in
perhaps i'm better when i don't give a
[ __ ] maybe
we had a conversation and i remember it
was in a coffee shop
in studio city and you raised your voice
you weren't yelling but you were very
uh assertive you were very uh this was
important to you so i
that thus began a a conversation that
everyone had to hear
and it was like well i don't understand
because you you
you you can't vision everyone in the
year
well you came from a vet i mean your
point was valid i remember
you said well i just like to work
i like to act i don't care if i'm on a
bad show i don't care if i'm in this i
want to perform i want to act i want to
work
and we had two different sort of ideas
in fact i think we might have talked
about this and
with monica on the plane you're a
monster come up a bunch between you and
i yeah
it's an ongoing disagreement and i i i'm
sort of like
maybe it's because i had success with
acting at a younger age
well younger but and i kind of burn out
and i was just like i just don't i wanna
i have to love what i'm doing now
maybe and maybe all of a sudden you hit
your stride
you went from you know you were on
punk'd and you did growlings and all
this but you had to
really we all had to earn it but you
really had to grow and grow in this role
in this role and
and maybe you know you maybe you're
starting to get burned out of it now
you're understanding my point well no i
think
for me and by the way this this was
my point then and it remains my point
and by the way i'm not judgmental of
anyone
operating out of ego i operate on out of
ego in so many
realms of my life but i do recognize
that me wanting to be on breaking bad
is my ego because i want people around
town to bump into
me and say oh my god i love your show
right
and and i want to have died with having
been on these great shows but but then
another part of my brain recognizes my
children are never going to see breaking
bad
they're not gonna rediscover it that it
goes away
it happened it goes away there's no
permanence
there's no it doesn't matter i'm gonna
die
and whether or not i leave behind me 700
episodes of amazing tv or 700 episodes
of terrible unwatchable tv
there's really no difference in that
outcome because no one beyond my life is
gonna
evaluate that so all my life really will
have been
is how much fun did i have making the
700 terrible or good or
or great episodes and how much did they
pay me right
i i think the rest i think is my ego now
and again i don't mind that
but here's like yes you like great shows
and my point to you is always like then
watch great shows turn them on enjoy
them
you don't have to be in them look
i i agree to a point i think my approach
was i think your kids will watch them
but first of all it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter because you're dead
no it doesn't matter so look of course
there's ego i have a lot of ego
and [ __ ] i've worked on it and we both
have
i think for me it's like look a if i
couldn't afford like if i have a family
or if i couldn't afford something i will
do whatever it is
i don't care if they're doing whatever
i'm not gonna
bad now the show i mean i will but i i
don't
i would do it i would do whatever it
takes to get have money to
provide but if i'm lucky enough where i
could
make those decisions i'd much rather
spend my time on a show that has
that i'm really proud of that is
actually uh
i stretch i uh i'm challenged uh i i'm
like i can't wait to tell people to
watch this
as opposed to hey i'm on the show that i
don't even like
that's my point it's a great point but i
had this experience over the last
couple years which was i was on the
ranch on netflix
it has a humongous audience i've never
met a single person in hollywood that's
watched it
not one and i know several hundred
people in los angeles
and not one human being in our industry
has watched the ranch
now when i go do a live show around the
country
i meet a ton of people that like the
ranch that it has five million viewers
um so what i'm really doing is i'm
elevating
the opinion of my peers above the five
million people that watch the show and
enjoy it
first and foremost right i've decided i
want my peers approval
and not this five million people because
i think it goes without saying neither
of us are talking about a show that has
no audience then
that's moot yeah you can't be on a show
with no audience oh i've had those shows
okay but they don't last you're not on
them for long so my point is like
if you're on a show that has an audience
now you're talking about
what audience are you proud to have
and that's kind of ego because there's
no humans more valuable than another so
the 5 million people that love the ranch
versus the 5 million people that love
the parenthood
the only difference was some of those
people that love parenthood were my
peers so it felt better my ego
felt more stroked by the fact that it
was my peers as opposed to
these other five million people so once
i acknowledge there's no hierarchy in
who likes it
you know or it'd be shitty of me to
think there's a hierarchy
i then go to okay so i probably wouldn't
watch the ranch none of my peers watch
the ranch
but to your point if i want to be proud
of the work i did
ironically i had some scenes in the
ranch that i think are the best i've
ever had as an actor
like the final of that show i actually
had the experience
i've had the experience on parenthood
where i'm trying to be emotional
and then i had like the the transcended
experience on the ranch where it was
like i was so emotional i was trying not
to be emotional which is what would
have really happened in that situation
and i was trying not to cry
and i was failing at that and i've never
had that experience that's true
yeah yeah i haven't had it on another
project and there were
tons of other projects that were maybe
you know quote in our industry better
but my personal experience and my
personal accomplishment
probably peaked on that show that none
of my peers will watch
yeah no valid point i think ultimately
though at the end of the day
it's not a matter of like the midwest
watching it or hollywood watching it or
whoever watches it
it's and it's not even about you
watching it's like do you
like working do you if you like the work
for instance if ashley's
exactly yeah process do you like process
i like processing you like all process
because i'm not a big fan of all process
i i don't like
look i'll do it maybe but you know
people think of hollywood they think of
it just all glamour i've had friends
come on every set
i've ever been on and go god man you're
doing that [ __ ] thing again what the
[ __ ] they've already shot oh there's
nothing better than bringing someone to
set
it's so exciting for four and a half
minutes and then they can't wait to get
the
[ __ ] out of there it's so great
everybody everybody
even if it's their favorite show doesn't
matter you bring them
after five minutes they're like wait
this is so boring yeah then by adding
the fifth tape they're going i don't
know if lex luthor would say that either
that's kind of
i didn't like your reaction the last one
yeah i didn't ask you so
but yeah i mean look it's it's i get i
get it you like work i
i like look you also worked with ashton
kutcher who was one of your
close friends so if ashton wasn't in or
some other guys weren't in it that you
knew
would you have done it uh it's hard to
say i definitely
did it because of ashton and uh because
the pay wasn't there initially so i
wouldn't have done it for the pay
uh that then they did pay me when i came
on as a regular which was nice but
um look i i was in the movie the judge
right uh
[ __ ] uh you name them they're in them
dinofrio
uh [ __ ] uh robert downey jr
uh great santini uh what was his name
robert duvall
the point is everyone there's a
phenomenal actor they're all much better
actors than i am right
the pleasure i had on that set by the
way i did the same thing on that set
which is i told a bunch of jokes i tried
to make everyone laugh
and i got approval and i loved it and
the same thing was happening on the
ranch
so the for me the experience is almost
identical it's just a place for me to go
to try to be entertaining to people so
you like
it's not even the acting as much as it
is how do i entertain people
between takes i think you and i both
share bob i think you and i don't share
that it's exhausting but that's what we
do
yes and that's why i love this job it's
a job where you're you're encouraged to
[ __ ] around and delay working and be
funny and you know who else has that job
where like
you know the boss is thrilled that you
were a [ __ ] goofball the whole day
it's the dream well if that if you're
saying that then the next time you
direct something if you want to pay me a
decent amount of money just to come and
entertain the
the crew maybe do some stand-up in
between takes i'd love to do that
i can't see me directing anything for
another few decades so i hope you still
have the stamina in your 60s
why why don't you want to direct
anything um
for those things that we talked about
which is i have a five-year-old and
seven-year-old
um directing a movie is two years of
your life
you get one paycheck for those two years
it could [ __ ] tank
and or it could be humongous and i
that that cost reward analysis doesn't
appeal to me as much as it once did well
how long do you work on a set how long
do you work on um
bless this house bless this mess what
was canceled do you know that
oh i'm sorry i know you enjoyed that
it's totally okay
um i did enjoy it i really thought the
show was really funny i loved it i loved
watching with my kids i loved all the
dude
oh come on parham uh you know lake
uh the whole cast was insane it was it
was definitely the funniest cast i've
been a part of
so i loved it but it was 65 hours a week
for
seven months of the year and i have
three other jobs so
just getting the time back definitely
softened the blow
of you know my ego right
having my show canceled but well i guess
my point is if seven months 65 hours a
week
why couldn't you do a two and a half
month movie that's
less than half of that you could go back
and direct something i know it's
well because i gotta write for a year
okay you do that at home and then you
gotta prep
and then you gotta shoot for a couple
two and a half months then you gotta
edit for three months then you get a
test then you gotta go promote
it's two years yeah you're right but i
just remember how you know you were good
at it not only but you were passionate
about it
and i knew you had fun doing it and
and i just you know i remember the joy
you had i mean
forget time you know so i there's
nothing i like more than
production i there's nothing i enjoy
more than directing the movie now
the year beforehand i don't love it's
lonely writing
and then the stress of editing and
testing
is not fun i wouldn't say uh
of course you get a huge sense of pride
as you
make it better and better and all those
things and you test higher all that
stuff's rewarding but
you know the fun part of the two years
is the two months you're shooting
and again that's a lot of that's a lot
of months that aren't
fun to have the two fun months
and i it's not like i i left directing
and went to um back to tasseling corn i
i left
directing and i i'm on a sitcom and i
have a podcast and i host
top gear and i have a game show those
are all really fun things
you know i mean do you think you'll want
to act again or like or not not like you
know you know direct movies do you think
you'll
do i know we had this conversation but
it seems like
we both love doing our podcasts we both
like go man i
kind of this is this is great i'm
fulfilled i have great fans and
listeners and i enjoy it i feel like i'm
making a difference i'm
i'm improving as a human being uh you
know i guess when does it become enough
because i see you do all these things
and you're
two kids we gotta what's uh lincoln's
what seven
yeah five and seven five in dakota yeah
so i'm like holy [ __ ] man
you got this family you got it it's just
you do so much
and sometimes i wonder why do these
people why does my friend
do as much as that why doesn't he just
show the [ __ ] out
why why what is it psychologically that
you just need to do more and more and
more and more
well i think there's there's a there's
many many reasons why one one is um
i'll start with the grossest i'm uh i
have a huge fear of
financial insecurity despite the fact
that i have no financial insecurity it
doesn't matter because fears aren't
generally reality based so
you know i'm from a very modest
background and my mom built this
business and
and money was a big priority in our
lives and and sacrifice for money was
what you did and so
you know i have a hard time if someone
calls me and says hey
you want to make x amount of money in a
week by filming 10 episodes of a game
show in a week
and i'm gonna say no i think i'm good
without that money i can't imagine
saying that but
so that there's that uh
two uh all those things
i actually enjoy doing right so it's not
like
none of them am i on my way there going
like i gotta [ __ ] do this
i i don't have that feeling so there's
there's no downside the only the only
real stress is like again bless this
messes so many hours i'd start going
like
[ __ ] i don't like that i'm just either
waking my girls up and driving them to
school or putting them down i i don't
like having to decide
if i only get to do one of those things
i don't love that
i bring my kids to set it's so [ __ ]
boring i feel terrible for him
then i regret it oh why'd i bring him
here well i wanted to see him oh there's
nothing for them to do
uh you know that all happens but
uh there's a uh strike one of the irons
hot
mentality uh i just wanna stockpile
money so i'm not ever
look you know what i don't want to do i
don't want to be 80
uh playing a guy who poops his pants in
a scene that no one knows their name
because i need the money
i could be and i don't want to be in
that spot check that part i probably
will take this
i'll take that fart yeah i'll take that
fart i'll take that shark
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon
you guys if you haven't tasted this
cereal you're gonna have to taste it
just listen to me trust me because i
wouldn't say this but my friends
i told you like a few weeks ago were
sitting around the house and i brought
out some magic spoon in the boxes
and all my friends freaked out i'm not
saying that ask him
all right sue me if i'm lying ethan tom
joe
dineen they all really enjoyed it
and i enjoy it too and i urge you to get
some magic uh spoon
here's the thing about magic spoon when
you're a kid you eat all these uh
cereals with sugar and crap
all in them right and you're like oh
this is great you get the you can't do
that as an adult i
was 48 years old i'll be asleep in 30
minutes after i eat the thing ryan
yeah i mean even at 32 i would right too
much sugar man it's not good for us
we're getting old uh-huh
but breakfast is the is the best part of
every day for me and um
why can't i enjoy it like i did when i
was a kid i can't
i freaking can it's magic spoon let me
tell you something zero sugar
11 grams of protein three net grams of
carbs in each morning
you can feel like a kid again and i like
their flavors too
what's your favorite i'm gonna go with
one on the count of three
one two three frosted
dude seriously did you look at my lips
when i said it
did you look at mine i can't you're
wearing a mask i love frosting i also
love
cocoa that's good too yeah it's i mean i
actually like all of them they're all
all really good frosting cocoa it tastes
like fruity nostalgic
really and the blueberries kind of like
a boot uh well i won't say it i won't
say what it tastes like i know
uh yeah i really like this stuff uh it's
honestly too good to be true
it's keto friendly it's gluten free it's
grain free soy free
low carb and gmo free i think you guys
are gonna love it
please try it go to magicspoon.com
iou to grab a variety pack and try it
today
and be sure to use the promo code iou at
checkout to get free shipping
and magic spin is so confident in their
product it's backed with 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason what happens ryan
you'll get your money refunded no
questions asked that's magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou for free
shipping we thank magic spoon for
sponsoring
our podcast distracted driving is a
serious problem
on our roadways leading to the deaths of
thousands of people and injuries in the
hundreds of thousands each year
when you take your eyes and your focus
off the road even for a second
it can be deadly not just for you but
for other
drivers pedestrians and bicyclists sadly
many americans use their cell phones
while driving whether it's texting
checking emails scrolling media feeds or
any other form of distraction drivers
are putting themselves and others around
them at great risk
it's important to know that 48 states
ban
texting and driving also 21 states
prohibit all drivers from using cell
phones while driving
distracted drivers are not only putting
people at risk they're also breaking
the law look it's dangerous to use your
cell phones behind the wheel that's why
law enforcement officers write tickets
and enforce hands-free and anti-texting
and driving laws
when you're driving put down your phone
and keep your hands on the wheel
your eyes on the road and your mind and
the task of driving
remember you drive you text
you pay brought to you by nhtsa
yeah you know i'm just i'm probably
overly pragmatic about
uh you know hopefully it'll be a long
ride and i'm gonna need money
40 years from now so
you know yeah well that's just amazing
to me you don't have as many
financial fears as i do well i don't
yeah and i know you don't like you know
we don't talk about money but it's like
you have a
you're a very successful actor podcaster
direct all that kristin's tremendously
uh
blah blah blah you both are very so you
have two people that are making money
yeah and my agents are always telling me
you i i just
i don't know if some of it's fear some
of it's just i don't want to be do that
i don't want to
there's a lot of stuff that goes through
my head but let's listen i definitely
look at my finances
every month and go i still do this since
i was a kid since i was uh no in new
york and i go
you have 900 you could pay rent for one
month you could eat
you could rollerblade to work this week
because you work at uh emergency skills
incorporated um on the phone
telemarketing
you could and then also then i got money
when i was 26 like okay first season of
smallville wow
it went all the way through even today
like you could actually live eight years
if you did nothing and i start that's
what i do
where i'm like i don't think about
getting more and more and more and more
like my agent's like dude you could do
this and this and i
i just want to be comfortable i really
do i just want to
the second somebody goes oh you have
nothing left i'm like oh
give me give me a job oh here's the
great irony all of it is is that
you you met me right after i had been
living for 10 years in la on eight grand
a year
i did that for 10 years and i almost
never thought about money
[Laughter]
and then when i got money and started
thinking about money all the time
like when i had none it was just like oh
you got none you got eight grand a year
you got to pay this rent you half of 600
bree paid the other half and then i got
to stay drunk five nights a week that
you know what's the cheapest way i can
do that
and once it was all dialed it was like
it was just on like
auto auto deduction like okay i'm gonna
make eight grand and then i'm gonna
spend it on this and it's all
and i'm gonna save 500 a year like and
then it was over i didn't even think
about it
but i do the same thing as you i'm like
okay how long can we live
and i have kids and the kids got to go
to college and the kids blah blah blah
so i just i work through that scenario
and then all that happens is there's
different permutations like i go
okay well how long can we live with this
lifestyle
okay okay so what if we scaled it back
by this then we could live this long
but it's just endless and it's pointless
and i
recognize it's a racket and there's it's
all foe security there's no security in
life
the [ __ ] this coronavirus came around
and just started laughing at everyone oh
everyone planned for this check this out
everyone's gonna sit in their [ __ ]
home for the next three months
was that in your plan so i recognize
it's all an
illusion of security which is not to say
that i i
i'm able to uh you know detach myself
from it i
i i still obsess about it do you i guess
part of that question was i mean if i
were you i'd go
what how much is enough shepard yeah how
much is enough that's what i was
thinking because i know
that look it's obvious it's not like you
know obviously you guys have
way more money money's not look it's i'm
just saying
like it doesn't matter i'm not gonna go
there it doesn't matter okay
what i will say is well here's what i
can tell you about what's enough
okay i know because it's already
happened whatever number i were to tell
you
the day i reach that number it there'll
be a new number
that i know about myself okay that's
good i like it listen
and by the way when you and i were when
you and i were 18 and we lived in the
midwest
yeah if someone told us we had a million
dollars oh my god
i'm telling you i would have been like
sweet i get a [ __ ] uh
a mastercraft ski boat i get a 79 bronco
pennies [ __ ] card yeah and then i'm
done
by the way not a million when i was a
kid in indiana i go
i make a hundred thousand dollars i'm
leaving this world oh i thought it was a
hundred thousand
i thought a hundred thousand dollars
would get you and then you're like wow
hundred thousand dollars will last most
families oh maybe a year
yes well in in in my paradigm the people
that made that were the engineers at
general motors so my whole life was
automotive everyone i knew was somehow
in that world and
if you got to like i don't know seventh
level at gm as an engineer you could
make a hundred grand so for me
that was virtually the the ceiling of
what someone could make so yeah
and then the second you make that you
know the million dollars on smallville
all of a sudden you're friends with some
[ __ ] who's making five million
dollars a year
and that's part of what drives the
insanity is
right okay that's good this is where i'm
going
so my question is with all this stuff
and all the money and
you know the marriage and the kids and
all this
you think that don't you want a quieter
time
don't you want to be able how much time
do you really have to spend
with your friends how much time do you
really have in general
because do you miss those times in
michigan
do you miss those times of just when it
was just simpler and you didn't have
that much responsibility
and you it do you ever think do you ever
uh reflect do you ever um
what's the word uh evaluate or revert
back to old behaviors or go oh [ __ ] i'm
trying i'm thinking a certain way like
you used to i gotta i gotta correct that
well i will say uh now i just admitted
all that gross stuff about me how much i
think about money and obsessed with it
but i i will say i do think i'm pretty
uh balanced like so i still have tons of
hobbies i still go off-roading all the
time i have like
a group of friends i ride on the
motorcycle track with that i race with
there there's do i have like sand dune
buddies i have
um actor buddies i i have i have a big
friendship group and and and i spent a
lot of time with that
group all things considered the fact
that i do have these jobs
and increasingly as you've pointed out
you know my my
calculus to whether or not i want to
work on a job is like what's the bang
for the buck can i make 10 episodes in a
week yeah sign me up
top gear i'm on top gear we can shoot an
episode in two and a half days
that beats the [ __ ] out of being on an
hbo show an episode of game of thrones
takes 13 days you know
so that stuff starts becoming part of
the analysis
you want to maybe it's not it's not a
bad thing it's kind of it's what i want
i mean i'd love to
feel like i'm doing nothing but still
making a living
sure i think that's i think that's
that's we would all like that yeah i
mean that's
i mean really who wants to who wants to
work but but increasingly i'll also say
this
a big part of the equation now also and
this is from like i look up to people
like danny mcbride
who clearly didn't ever prioritize money
he only prioritized working with friends
and i think he's the big winner in all
this i think there's probably people who
make more money but
like and i think sandler did that
brilliantly i think the people who
recognize okay i'm gonna work that's
gonna be very time consuming
but i have the ability to spend all that
time with friends
then you're just you're winning so
that's you know like chris and i are
going to do it again a game show and
it's like yeah that won't be a job i'll
just be with
kristin and that's ideal hanging out i'm
working with my favorite person
and and i'll get paid so you know you
said something awesome on an interview
you said um it was the first time in a
relationship
where you felt like in your other
relationships you tried to make the
person you're dating
more like the person you want to date or
something like that i'm paraphrasing but
with kristin you didn't do that it was
the first time you made a conscious
effort not to sort of go there and say
hey i'm not gonna
try to mold turn to what i want and i
thought that was really interesting
because i think i've been 21 and older
like
another n-word molder that's a jay-z
line
but i really i don't know yeah yeah yeah
uh you know
uh yes um never never consciously i've
never like i'm
i'm not a psychopath i've never like
dated someone like i'm gonna
i'm gonna turn them into the person i
want but slowly i argue with people
they have a position on something i try
to convince them of my way of thinking
and
and i just do that and then you look at
it cumulatively over time and you're
like
oh i think of i think i was you know i
think i was trying to get this person to
think exactly like me but why would the
[ __ ] would i want to be with someone
that thinks exactly like me to stay by
myself
exactly why am i doing this like what
you should be looking to add someone to
your life that
thinks completely different that has a
different skill set that that basically
doubles your life
in its scope and world view and and
you know i i had that commitment when i
met kristen and a lot of the stuff
for me personally was challenging i was
like
do you believe that jesus was the son of
god
and then he rose for our sins and she
said yes and i was like
my first thought was oh no i i want to
have kids with this person
is she going to tell them that they're
going to go to hell if they sin like i
go to
all these fears about what her believing
in that well
how it'll negatively impact me because
i'm a selfish [ __ ] and it all is
about how will it
impact me and i just thank god for the
first time my life had the foresight to
go
don't even touch that that's great you
think that
awesome i'll worry about the kids thing
when that
uh and guess what many years later we
had kids and that's not an issue
i even wrestle with so it would have
been a complete waste of my energy and
time
and it never even ended up bearing the
the poisonous fruit i was afraid it
would
by the way i just thought wow i wish
everybody would marry someone who's sort
of the opposite in thinking or
have because then maybe kids would be
more normal
because if two parents believe one thing
that kid is going to spend the rest of
his life
saying what mommy and daddy said i
believe what they said and
that just carries on but when two people
two you know you kristen
you know they could listen to your
arguments and make their own decision
ultimately
yeah and you know we we do have a kind
of family rule in our house which is
best argument wins so
when we tell them they can't do
something or they're you know whatever
the
numerous rules you got to put in place
as a parent which blows
uh they have their day in court right
and quite often
they win like if they can make a really
salient argument
and it's logic based and we will we will
concede defeat if if they if they argue
well you know we
we share the same fear you know you said
you know i
think that you've said this before but
like you always imagine yourself as not
a very bright person obviously you're
very bright
but i've always thought of myself like
that and because of my dysfunction in my
life and my family and my history
it's like when someone tells you you're
dumb or you're not smart at young age or
you have disabilities or whatever
you believe that no matter what anybody
tells you those developmental years
are crucial and i have felt that so
i mean that's uh you know i don't know
where i was going with that
but i mean i i'm just well even more
than the people
telling you which who knows what the
effect of that is but
you and i i think if i know your history
correctly like
i got called on in class you know
kindergarten to fifth grade when i had
you know uh terrible dyslexia and it was
undiagnosed where they call on me and
i'm pretty certain that word says this
and i say it out loud and then everyone
laughs
and it's not even the other people
telling me i'm a dumbass i'm
learning real time i'm a dumbass like i
thought it was that word
and it's not [ __ ] it's oh it's scary
because yeah i didn't walk around
thinking i was like a dumbass
or couldn't comprehend the world around
me yet when you when you put these
letters these symbols on that chalkboard
i [ __ ] don't know any i'm the worst
in the class
and i've said it a million times i when
i get a d or an f in art class and
she's like what what is this that's not
green that's a and i
you know i'm colorblind and i just oh
but i don't know anything other than
yeah i don't know why i don't know this
so i am dumb
because no one fails art i'm dumb in
fact you'd be dumb not to conclude you
were dumb
oh yeah that would be like the proof you
were dumb real he didn't recognize you
were dumb
yeah i recognized i was dumb which is
dangerous
but this is this is what this is my
point the reason i feel like i
have not gotten married there's a lot of
reasons i'm sure you know most of them
but big one is i can't imagine teaching
my
daughter or son math or science or
reading with them
and then i'll go back to going i don't
understand this now
i'm really dumb that really scares me
that i can't educate my children the way
that they should probably be educated
but can i tell you something
homework-wise the the best education you
could give them
is is relating to them uh
empathizing with them sharing in their
frustrations saying
i too couldn't learn this and look i
wasn't dumb
the [ __ ] math spelling that's not the
thing you need to learn in life the
thing you need to learn in life
is resilience is you know how to be a
good human being
is character in what you could always
educate a kid on his character and you
could
always identify and share and let them
know you you
you know how they feel and they're not
alone and they're not the first person
to have this struggle that that's what
you got to teach your kid not [ __ ]
algebra when's the last time you did a
quadratic equation
well i don't want to get into uh
pythagoreans theorems
y squared plus b squared always equals
seed squared hey
do you hate do you hey i know you talk
about this i'm sure you've asked us to
answer this question
but do you do you hate being called like
sort of america's couple the perfect
couple does that make it harder if you
it's got to make it harder if you ever
want to get divorced right it's like
[ __ ] now they're all going to think the
perfect couple
i mean do you ever think like that well
i i think i'm very realistic
about if we were to get divorced
america would most certainly side with
her there's no
it doesn't matter what the facts would
have
made me feel i agree they would even if
she like it was
it came out that she was [ __ ] 69 in
lebron james in a
target parking lot i know people would
be like
well dax should have 69 or he must have
pushed her
to that parking lot uh so i have no
illusion that that america wouldn't
side with her i've even taken it as far
as i probably would be unemployable
or maybe they'd let me play villains in
movies you know uh
but in general yeah i would come out on
the business end of that separation
i am not unaware of that and yet
life would go on all the more reason
i'll be glad i stockpiled some money
that is the best answer you could
possibly give
let's just call a spade a spade i mean
what are you like what do you like
do you argue about is it usually the
same thing is that you have a certain
thing where you're like
you have a trigger you get mad she has a
trigger she cries she gets mad is there
something that you know
you don't go down that path oh there's
there's a hundred and again you know the
details aren't
necessarily relevant it's all about like
the pattern like if you can recognize
the pattern
and then you can just plug anything into
that pattern uh she leaves the [ __ ]
doors of the cabinets open all the time
she don't even put the lids on her
[ __ ] medication
i go to get a nails clipper and i bump
something and now there's pills all over
you know
it the the the specifics are immaterial
it's like what pattern do we endlessly
find ourselves in
and and how do we divert out of that
pattern
and what do you do do you calmly sit
there i i okay here's
i can only tell you my side of the
street which is and this is all from a
if we're having a conversation and i
noticed my breathing changes
uh my chest is a little tighter and now
my volume's gone up a bit but i don't
even realize my volume's gone up a bit
uh that i know a hundred percent of the
time
whatever the thing is we're debating
whether it's the cabinets or the
medicine i have a fear that's being
triggered
uh and i need to go into a room and
figure out what fear is being triggered
and until i know what fear is being
triggered until i can share with her
what fear is being triggered
uh the rest of the debate's gonna be a
waste of time
because i just don't care about things
that don't trigger fears in me
there's a million things she does that
are objectively offensive as a human
like a human
if a human is throwing something in a
trash can they should make sure it lands
in the trash can and if it doesn't they
should take the time to
put it in that trash can now i'll walk
into the bathroom and i'll see there's
like
any number of tissues and some q-tips
and you name it just
around the trash can it doesn't bother
me i find it
you know objectively wrong but it
doesn't bother me i'm like yeah
you know what man she gets as close as
she can and that's enough for her
and then there's some other thing that
is less objectively offensive that i am
off to the races on
because it triggered she cares about
work more than me or she cares about
family more than me
she cares about something more than me
as i feared my mother did
and that's what's going on and i need to
need to get vulnerable and tell her
i'm afraid you care about that thing
more than me and she literally goes
honey i don't care about
anything more than you and then it's
over and i believe her
you know but i got to get to that point
where i can go i'm afraid you care about
that thing more than me
that's incredible that's incredible that
you learn that that feeling because i
get that feeling
and i never know what to do with it and
i and first of all if i if you didn't
say that i think
well this is the feeling i get when i'm
upset when someone's upset me or when
i'm just i'm i'm unhappy so
there's a trigger here i don't think all
right whatever this is
you don't need to go out with it this is
you get some something
right then something talk to yourself go
in another room because
whatever comes out of your mouth
probably isn't going to be good and it's
going to come out of a dark place
my favorite example of this well i have
two one is
you could dedicate the remaining
thousand episodes of your podcast
to how short dak shepard is that could
be you could even entitle the podcast
jack shepard is so short too short
you could do a thousand episodes it'd
never
bother me because i don't have any fear
of being too short
i am objectively tall i don't have a
fear of being too short so you could
spend the rest of your life trying to
make fun of me for being short and it
wouldn't
bother me now if you had a podcast
called dax is
self-centered and sucks up too much
energy in a room
i'm bothered by that because i do do
that and i have a fear that i do that
and so it would bother me intensely and
it would bother you but you know they
were right so how what do you do about
that you try to change yourself
or did you say i'm innately that way
because i do that i'm like i go in a
room
and whether it's insecurity i don't
think they're going to like me for me
i'll be funny i'll be this
it's something that i'm not it's
something at a young age i did because i
didn't like myself
i wasn't confident with my looks
whatever it was i did and now i
entertain and people like me i'm like
okay i got him i got him and i could
[ __ ] know okay
right so so all that is is an internal
job right that that's a michael
rosenbaum job that no one else has
anything to do with
right you can pretend they do but they
don't and and i do think that
all of our problems each individual
person on this planet
their problems have nothing to do with
anyone else
those other people just trigger
their fears and their insecurities and
then that's the problem
like if you if you're if your
self-esteem was literally a thousand
percent
as i'm saying if if if my confidence in
every aspect of my personality was the
same as my confidence in that i'm not
short
i wouldn't have problems because
everyone could be saying whatever they
were saying and it would never bother me
so all of all that to say my only
problem is dax and making sure dax is
self-esteem is it it's the optimal level
as high as it can get and then i don't
have problems anymore
i can't wait for the world to change
around me i have to change
me inside of you is brought to you by
vincero
these watches are dope look at this ryan
you never see me in a watch you know why
no
because i don't feel comfortable in
watches this one i actually feel like
it's it just goes with me it's subtle
and it's classy can you see that i
really like this watch
and i'm really excited that vincero
is uh coming on as a sponsor we are
partnering with
vincero watches i'm extremely excited
about this and i
welcome them to be my sponsor making a
statement doesn't have to cost a fortune
folks with vincero you can elevate your
look
for an affordable price they believe you
deserve to look good and feel good no
matter your budget there was that thing
on saturday night live remember it's
better to look good than to feel good
sometimes that's true i don't always
feel good so i might as well look good
vincero creates exceptionally crafted
watches and they do it without breaking
the bank like i said
the guys over there sent us a couple and
uh i'm wearing it i'm wearing them and
i'm gonna wear the silver one i have i
got this black one
uh i'm really excited and they're
stunning i think i thought that'd be
five times
the price they're offering you as a
listener 15 off your entire order and
they are going to cover all
shipping costs if you visit
vincerowatches.com
y o u v i n c e r o w
a t c h e s dot com slash
y o u they're honestly look at this ryan
i know i was gonna say you class it up
today
i know i was thinking about even wearing
pants i think the watch does the trick
the watch helps you know it really does
pants when you get a watch
yeah who needs pants if you have a watch
uh these are bold watches
sexy looking um perfect conversation
starter for sure
and that's especially for me people
you're wearing a watch i'm like yeah
cause look at this watch
and as they say even if you claim not to
be a watch person vincero has styles for
men and women
as well as an array of accessories
wallets bracelets extra straps
sunglasses all made with the same
incredible quality as their
watches and that is why they have over
000 five-star reviews on their website
you can go and read them for yourself
yeah and they're offering free shipping
free returns for 30 days and a warranty
on your watch for up to two years
that is pretty wild it is really
stress-free shopping right at home it's
so easy so
guys don't overpay for a watch it looks
cheap and disappoints exclusively for
our listeners vincero is giving you 15
off their already affordable watches go
to vincerowatches.com
backslash y-o-u don't you dare pay full
price at checkout go to my link and
code y-o-u will be auto-apply to check
out
it is that easy this is a buy you won't
regret by the way i'm not kidding
that once i i just i i could go forever
i'm not going to
but like i this is this is easy for me i
forget how easy it is to talk to you and
be so open and
uh i just i i you know i always
reminisce i always think about you know
all the things we we used to do and i'm
sort of one of those people that
you know i'm definitely one foot in the
past one foot in the future and pissing
on the president
i've always been like that like i'm just
i'm like i remember i almost brought me
to tears i heard an 80s song yesterday
and i remember i would not i'm saying
this out loud but i remember i got a
tear in my eye and go god i just
how do i get back i know i know really
i want i got god how can i i mean if
there is a heaven
i think there is i i hope that when you
die the subconsciously whatever it is
that you
love maybe you don't even know how much
you love it till you die and you're
there
that it that whatever that is you die
and that
all that shit's released in your brain
what's that called dmt what the [ __ ]
shit's that called
the god drug whatever it is yeah well
whatever it is it's in your brain it
releases when you die i'll send you an
article
but anyway when you die you go to the
place you're like yeah
i'm walking down land view drive to
danny cutter's house and
his brother's got an el camino and
[ __ ] van halen jumps playing i'm
gonna go downstairs in the basement and
play
atari pac-man and the [ __ ] that it's
raining and then there's a tornado and
shotsy and cricket are kind of taking it
almost blowing away and the [ __ ]
winds are almost like lifting the dogs
up and ron and brothers grabbing them
and
i'm like i don't know what it is simpler
times moments because not all of my
childhood is brilliant
but i i miss a certain just
innocence of like god i didn't think
about work so much
all i thought about was how do i just
enjoy how do i just be in this moment
you didn't think about it
but what's ironic uh it it appears to me
what's appealing about that phase of
your life is that you
actually were present like the thing
that you're nostalgic for the feeling
it's not about van halen it's not about
all those details
your emotional state it sounds like was
present
was like yeah in the time you were in
you were occupying the
the slice of time and space that you
were in
you weren't trying to get somewhere you
didn't have aspirations yet you weren't
evaluating yourself yet
against all these other people who had
similar aspirations and where they're at
and what you really miss is a
contentment and a presence
and so the irony being of course is that
you you're leaving the present today to
want to be there
and so it's like for you to be there
would be to stop wanting to be there
you could be there again you could walk
out your [ __ ] driveway right now
and go god damn i live on this street i
bought this place i can take a stroll no
one can say i can if i want to walk all
the way down the hill and get a [ __ ]
slurpee
i can do it uh i could stop at [ __ ]
uh
your buddy's house life's too short not
to hit your pool buddy
yeah harlan i mean you could choose
to be doing the exact thing in 1986 you
love
but there wasn't that feeling and maybe
there is there wasn't that feeling of
like
i gotta make money i gotta do this i
gotta impress
i gotta [ __ ] take care of that there
was just like i just gotta be home by
six i need some shitty dinner that my
mom's creating
and then go upstairs and pretend like
and then watch the thing
on tv that's playing i didn't there
wasn't there is that and there's always
like there's still that little kid
that's going
[ __ ] man all right i want to be grown up
i'm responsible i don't do drugs i try
to
i'm a good person for the most part i
try to be and then there's just like ah
and then you start to go back and forth
like how much do i really love
this how much do i really like myself
how much there's all that that always
kind of catches up with you
yeah but i i think you suffer from um
disproportionately is i think the weight
of
some trajectory in your mind you're
supposed to be on
uh is is is a lot is cumbersome for you
and by the way i haven't i've certainly
spent most of my
working life not being this way but i
have to say
um i've really transitioned into
comparing
myself to previous versions of myself
and no one else and i have found elation
in that
i i you know what right when you said
that
it made me think and i definitely like
myself better than i did
a year ago or six months maybe even then
yesterday
but but that doesn't it's look i'm on
the right path i think we all are i
think if we just like learned
you know it may sound like a stupid
question but it's like you know that
question when people say do you love
yourself that's always bothered me i've
asked
everyone someone that much but like you
know that's a
you should either love yourself you
should know the answer immediately
shouldn't you
hmm i'm guessing no
i don't know i don't know i don't know
if you should know it immediately
i think what would be really relevant is
what things uh because i don't think you
can think your way into feeling
differently i think you have to act your
way into feeling differently so
i think if i ask you right now rosenbaum
what's the five things on your list that
give you self-esteem what are they
uh i like when people uh
email the show or i read
fan letters or i bump into someone or on
my patreon some
and someone says your your podcast
changed my life
it um you know listening do you talk
about anxiety with the people that you
know it helps norma
whatever that does give me like a reason
like hey i'm doing something right
that's great but you know also
self-esteem sure when you're when you
have more listeners when you have more
uh sponsors when you have more a lot of
things that of course aren't that
important
but of course they feed that self-esteem
but i
i really tried to go hey i don't
need to make an exorbitant amount of
money i just want to
do something i love and and make a
living at it that's what everyone wants
to do
that's a tough question because yeah
there are things uh self-esteem wise
that we do when someone says oh you're
i don't need to hear them i guess i
don't need to hear that i think if
someone doesn't have a list of if they
don't know the things that give them
self-esteem how on earth could they be
working
on their self-esteem um
so you know for me mine is exercise
when i exercise it raises my self-esteem
i'm proud of myself
i did something that i didn't enjoy
doing for the betterment of myself long
term
uh if i eat healthy that gives me
self-esteem cause again i i rejected
something that was tempting uh for my
betterment
um i'm of service to people i don't want
to [ __ ] call people an a.a
i don't want to take someone through the
steps i don't want to do any of that
[ __ ] i don't want to [ __ ] host a
meeting at my house
but when i do something for other people
i feel i like myself more i can answer
that question i love myself and so
you know there's one needs to know what
things result in self-esteem
because they're not going to magically
arrive at it you know what
one thing that came to mind is when i do
things or i don't think
about what whether it's oh
what do you get from that or oh if you
do that you know this will
you know people will see it's altruism
it's
when the other day i was on my phone and
it says
i won't you know it's it on twitter i
don't know whatever it said a kid
uh graduates and on his drive home his
uh well him and his sister in the back
seat his parents are killed in a crash
on his graduation day that's most
exciting and immediately i i didn't
wait wait a bit i didn't think of
anything other than i have to
contact the school i have to find a way
to somehow help or donate or
whatever i didn't say who i was or not
that that matters but i just
i found the school and i and i wrote and
i genuinely did it from a place of just
love and
it almost made me emotional that i was
doing this because i
felt good and it felt like i had to do
that
yes and so and i think you and i share
this even though i'm not
i'm not willing to say you're an addict
i know nothing about that but what i
will say is
in naa uh even that altruism
is selfish which is totally okay in my
opinion
so i am of i believe that the source of
almost all my anxiety and depression
and all that stuff is thinking about
myself
if you give me time to think about
myself i will inevitably
start wondering where i'm ranking in
this world and i'll start comparing
myself to other people and i'll start
thinking of the things that dax doesn't
have that he should have
and the more time i spend thinking about
myself
the less happy i am maybe that's why you
do maybe that's why you're so busy
i think that's probably part of the
thing but i i know from service in a.a
it's pretty hard to be thinking about
what i do or don't have
while i'm helping someone else i just
get kind of sucked into their problem
or sucked into their thing and it just
it frees me from
thinking of myself and and so
you know one of the things with you is
like i don't think it's right or wrong
to be in a relationship or be married i
don't give a [ __ ] i have no position on
that
what i have a position on it the way i
think it could be hugely beneficial to
you is simply
you're gonna have to spend so much
goddamn time thinking about the other
person
and then the compromise that you guys
have to come to that
it kind of it takes away some of the
free time to
obsess about yourself and the things you
need and where you're at
and so it's like [ __ ] all the other
stuff it's just like get
some fill up that dance card with other
people's problems
and inevitably you have less time to
think about yours and really you don't
have [ __ ] problems because you're
full and there's a roof over your head
everything else is just
abstract right all right this is it this
is uh i i got my patrons my top patrons
ask questions and you just
spitfire this is uh dax shepherd [ __ ]
talking questions
answer them as quickly as you want
leanne since both dax and his wife are
successful
actors is it difficult to find a uh a
work home balance
uh it's really not we've i don't know
why
it's almost enough to make me believe in
a higher power uh
i get busy she gets time then she gets
busy and i get
time it's been freaky since we've had
kids generally our
very busy times have kept dosie doeing
jennifer ann would you do a horror film
if yes with who
what one did i say well like you think
about a get out or something you i'd
kill to be in that movie
right would you want to be a killer or
someone who's racing from the killer
i was just thinking of this for kristen
and i yesterday because we're both now
without
scripted television shows and i was like
wouldn't it be fun to maybe play on the
if i was a cynic well i am a cynic if i
was in america looking at kristen and i
i'd go
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he's probably gay
she's probably blank she's a junkie
there's no way this is real
so maybe i would love to do a horror
movie where we're like maybe like an
honored married
newscast team or something and then when
we're off work we're just
[ __ ] evil um you know what that'd be
funny because it plays on the whole
thing we're all jackson christian
america's couple they're cute they're
sweet and then also like
[ __ ] you and you're just stabbing people
i knew they were evil
i knew they were [ __ ] matthew if you
were to make another big studio produced
film
i imagine the challenges of working with
large studios like that are daunting
that's not really a question i had a
great studio experience
on chips i i thought it was great and to
have like the the
infrastructure that exists there uh
i just remember like day one on chips
going like oh my god if i had had this
[ __ ] on hit and run
i mean man does it make it easy a
[ __ ] porsche cayenne with a russian
arm on top and
best driver in the world driving and the
[ __ ] guy who shot all of uh
the [ __ ] uh bad boys action sequences
my as my dp are you kidding like this
boy this makes it easier
you said something awesome like in our
last interview you said something
because
uh you know we're talking about it and
you're like well you know chips didn't
have a big box office
success or whatever and you go but if i
went back to that i don't know that
13 year old kid in michigan or detroit
and said
hey little dax hey would you want to be
in a big movie
want to be a movie star i want to be in
a big motion picture and you get to
direct it
and ride motorcycles the whole time yeah
well that kid wouldn't go
well does it make a lot of money is it
because
is it a huge success i mean that's what
we lose i think that was the most
profound thing i've i've heard you say
or one of them because
that just puts everything in a brand new
perspective like do it because you love
it and if it has success great
it's hard to differentiate those things
yeah it really is i mean you know
you can't be naive like the success of
those things determines whether or not
you'll get to do it again so it is
relevant right but yes as a life
experience
whether that thing the life experience
was a life experience now it could have
made 500 million or in its case it made
28 million or whatever
uh the experience was the experience the
other thing was just
the results of which i don't control
right it really sucks if you had a
shitty experience
and it bombed but if you had a great
experience in a bomb it's not that bad
or a great experience
and it had oh my god but yeah i got you
claudine or i always wonder i always
wonder because
this is the thing i i did think about
like say the devil comes down and he
says
now you could either love the movie you
made and it makes 28 million
or you could totally have missed the
mark of what you were trying to make but
it's a huge success
i i don't think i would choose the
latter i don't think i would
want to have not made the movie i set
out to
to to get the reward of it you know well
the only thing i would say there is if
the movie made so much money that then
you're given another opportunity to do
what you want again and make it better
but wouldn't you be so fear laden
because you're like well the thing i
made last time didn't even turn out to
what i tried to make so if i try again
i can't get that lucky twice i just
wanted to survive
i just didn't want to die during the
making of my movie that's a lot i
remember praying to god and day like
15 i go hey if you just get me out of
this i don't
i'll never direct again just uh i
remember sitting in the back seat i've
told this story of tom and dineen who
you know my best friends
they're taking you to the hospital right
well no i i didn't
but we're driving it's like five in the
morning six in the morning and i'm in
the back seat and deneen's like oh chip
are going yeah so anyway
it's gonna be a great day blah blah blah
tom's like uh and i'm in the back seat
in the middle and i just go
i think i need to go to the hospital and
i
it was barely audible and deneen goes
what i go
to the hospital and then she goes it's
going to be a great day she didn't look
at me but if she would have turned
around we would have gone to the
hospital
claudine a question for dax well i would
hope so what's something he's learned
about himself since becoming a dad
um that's a good one
i want to give a good i want to like
there's
some things that are popping up but i
think
life lesson wise
you know you know i i know what it is
it's um
i think most of my life i've had the uh
the agenda to get my way
and i've been trying to be more clever
and and more tactful or tactical
and getting my way and when you have
kids especially if you have two you know
our first one was so [ __ ] easy
uh the way i would naturally parent was
yielding results i thought we were
geniuses that we should write a book
about it and then we had another kid
and just the opposite things worked for
that kid but i i spent a few years
uh being stubborn and trying to parent
her the same way as our firstborn
and all of a sudden i just had this
terrible realization i was like
oh i think i wrote my own father off at
about five years old
i was like okay it's your way or the
highway i picked the highway
[ __ ]
and i just had this moment i was like oh
they could pick the highway
like i could i could get i could win and
lose
so big and i gotta i gotta flip this
thing
wow so i just think having the
experience of like
prioritizing what you should prob what i
should have always prioritized in life
which is like
oh there's another human involved and
maybe i
i need to care as much about them
getting what they want out of this
experience
todd uh everyone geeks out on something
i can answer this what do you geek out
on besides
cars and motorcycles cars and
motorcycles and your kids
or your wife what do you geek out on my
not michael mcdonald this is the case
this is a dark one chris kristen hates
this um
i'm obsessed they're largely criminals
i'm obsessed with people who threw a
a force of will
did something impossible but my prime
example of it is
uh pablo escobar he is a poor kid living
on the streets
of medellin he has no shot at becoming
the eighth richest
man in the world that's off the table he
didn't invent microsoft
and just through his own will he's like
no i'm gonna become the eighth richest
man in the world
i'm a tr i'm somehow attract i'm
obsessed with these stories where people
just
and they're often delusional and through
that delusion and their their force of
will they they do something impossible i
i find that
endlessly interesting emily you like
that stuff do you like criminal [ __ ]
yeah i watch a lot of dateline um i know
we both love what's his name
it wasn't keith morrison december
oh october is whatever yeah that guy
it was a hot red moon under a nice cold
night and his
dude he's hilarious and what's his name
hater who does him on snl he used to do
him
oh so good he's hard to do i ca i can't
even get close you had him on your show
too oh
todd and he's so beautifully canadian he
just he kept going this feels so
self-indulgent to talk about myself
i'm like but people want to know about
you how do i want to do this
emily who's your favorite guest on
interview uh to interview an uh armed
armchair expert i have to give a couple
answers one obviously my mother is my
favorite
interview by far um but
if we if we take out that obvious
advantage she has
um i think dog the bounty hunter maybe
monica lewinsky all right just like when
you get something so unexpected like i
could have
i could have held dwayne in my arms
after the interview for about an hour
and a half
i think before it would have felt
awkward i just wanted
i was so shocked with what a beautiful
guy he was
what a sweetheart it was so lovely
angel two more questions since you guys
have been friends for a long time
uh share a funny dax rosie story what
what story do you think of that we could
actually tell
well look when you you and i met when we
were younger and uh we're both insecure
about how we look but we both like our
penises a lot so
you and i constantly had those swords
out all over town
yeah you know when i look back on it
we're pretty lucky times have changed we
wouldn't do that now
uh but we lived in maybe the last era
where you could get that sword out a lot
yeah and i don't you know we did and i
really it never was creepy or weird
i mean it's weird to just do it in
general but no what i'm saying is we
weren't going
doing things like it was just two like
little boys going hey
check this out dax hey check out my cap
hey check it
it was just like we didn't cap
yeah it was a long time ago and uh yeah
but i think to have known rosenbaum and
i in that
that era is to have seen us with our
pants down i think
probably that could have yeah that could
have happened bob
idiocracy in your opinion are we already
there
uh
no you know i um stephen pinker
he's a he's a genius he he's written a
lot of books
uh his most recent one is a is about the
enlightenment like maybe
pursuing the ideals of the enlightenment
i am of the opinion
that although in the present day
sometimes it looks like we're going
backwards i think if you look at the
long arc
this human experience we're getting
better and better and better
less and less people starve i think it's
good i think in the short term it
sometimes looks discouraging but
i think it's a really new experiment and
i think we're doing a good job at
getting better and better
uh this has been awesome i i wanted to
end this actually i wanted to start this
with just did we pull our dongs out not
anymore
it was uh that was uh 20 years ago we
shouldn't do that anymore
but i will say you know occasionally
when my friend rob or somebody comes
over
you know they might just like hey rob do
you want me to drink and they'll turn
around i'm like i'm naked
just uh just as a just a semblance you
know just a
just a little nostalgic come on dude
it's just harmless
it's a dong we're naked well you and i
find
look here's here's where i should i
should say this because it is relevant
you and i find that really funny we both
enjoy it and and
and we're we have the privilege of
finding it funny
what i've realized over time is like
yeah of course that's funny
because i'm a tall white dude
and i don't feel threatened a lot by
penises
um so it's a privilege that i can find
it humorous
um if i were a woman it wouldn't be so
funny
and if i were you know any number of
people i'm the most empowered someone
could be in our society so yeah
i think a lot of things are funny that
are scary to other people sure
but i i think that you know if i recall
i i just remember it was usually
you and i or other guys around for the
most part
i've had this experience on a set where
it's like you're nude with an actress
and i'm trapped in my own experience and
i'm kind of like
a bit no big deal i'm i'm nude but then
i have to
you know i have to recognize well yeah
85 percent of the crew is dudes no one's
going to go home and jerk off thinking
about me
no one's gonna you know there's all
these creepy i'm not dealing with the
same thing that the
actress is right absolutely it's
different i hear you and it's just it's
just being a it's being aware and going
okay i'm not this person i'm not i don't
feel
threatened you're right i remember one
time on smallville
it was one of the finales of the season
and they had me up on the
in the up at whistler in the middle of
nowhere but we were staying at this
hotel and everybody got the change there
you know just go a big like a big suite
and i walked in and one of the crew guys
is there and i'm like
hey i'm going to take a shower anybody
else here he's like oh barry
barry's uh you know he's in the shower
and i go oh
perfect he's like this you know at that
time he's 25 years older than he's an
older guy
and i love barry's my buddy so the first
thing i thought i was like
i got to do something you know sure so i
uh took off all my clothes and uh he i
waited until he was lathered up
really good and he was an irish fella
and i remember just going in there
could you pass the irish spring there
barry and he's like jesus
frozen bomb what the [ __ ] and then
he started laughing and then we you know
we both told the whole crew and
everybody it just went on forever and it
was just like
you can't do that anymore but of course
my whole thought was like how do i make
people laugh
how do i be funny right yeah i was
always out of a place of that i was
never out of a place where like hey i
want someone to see my d
yeah uh i was gonna end this we talk
about this i have i got autographs you
know that i have a house full of like
posters and things
you've never been you could listen to
the last conversation you say it's a
waste yeah
so i i did something i want to show it
to you but um you know one of my
favorite movies is the warriors
the gang movie absolutely right so for
four years
come out and play glory is good
real good the best but the rest is ours
anyway cyrus you see which what does he
say it's like
there are 20 000 cops in this city
can you dig it can you
you dig it i loved it love it so
we've got the bayside rollers sitting
next to the band
yeah so i'm a huge fan obviously you are
too a lot of people
are walter hill walter hill i'm trying
to get him on the podcast
sure my buddy's friends with him i just
love to talk he's probably going uh
another guy who wants to talk about the
warriors great
but he did a lot of other great movies
anyway so for i'm not kidding
since the late 90s i've been looking for
an original warrior's vest
something that was worn by the warriors
and it was impossible
the brown leather right yeah i think
yeah
and i had looked and i gave up because i
was like i heard that someone had one
but the cast never really kept the
originals and they were locked away and
there was only this they had some
doubles
so i was telling my friend and i just
said man i'll tell you if a warrior's
vest
ever comes up i will i'll pay two grand
for that thing
and i go you know what [ __ ] it and i
looked on my phone
and on ebay original warriors vest
warned by david harris who played
cochise the one with the big
bandanna black guy awesome yeah i know
you see him and it had a picture of him
it was authentic
oh and i just said are you kidding me
and i just messaged the guy back and i
go i'll give you a thousand
i wasn't gonna go for the two i would i
would have paid two but he's
you know i just got it for a grand let's
see what he says he goes sure
i'll take a thousand that sounds like a
bargain
oh dude now
this is the first piece of memorabilia
you
own that i'm thrilled with really oh
that is
nate tuck would [ __ ] cream his gene
if he saw this
in fact will you take a nice photograph
of it and send it to me so i can send it
to nate oh yeah you should actually look
on my instagram i posted a video
of me wearing the vest does it fit well
oh yeah
it fits really well i gotta work out a
little more i'll be honest with you yeah
the warriors were in shape for the most
part do you remember that the gang
there were a couple of them that you're
like this guy couldn't beat the [ __ ] out
of a piece of [ __ ]
well you know it's so interesting what
our memories of things are versus
like do you remember in urban cowboy
great film oh yeah yeah the antagonist i
forget that guy's name
wasn't his scott glenn scott glenn now i
was
telling kristin about scott glenn's
biceps in that movie and in my mind
my in my memory they're [ __ ]
normal like i never saw biceps like that
i go i look on
i look you know google images and
they're nice man they're nice bites
he's caught and he has a really nice
vein
but they're not at all what i thought in
in in in the bar has raised so
much you know with these superhero
movies and everything you now realize
like oh
they were pretty average looking guys
that i was
crazy for oh yeah well that's like with
anything i think i just watched
i loved gremlins as a kid and i put it
on and within 20 minutes i go can we
turn this off guys
like no no what are you talking about
i'm like this doesn't hold up at all
what a piece of [ __ ]
interesting i still watch it every
christmas i i like it
i i just it was just it's so i couldn't
i i can't get into you couldn't do it
but yeah as much as i like horror after
friday the 13th one or
halloween one i'm out can't do it
there's nothing scary about a guy who
can't be killed
he just can't be killed at least there's
like it's just like everyone's gonna die
but if you could if you could stop the
paranormal thing or you could stop the
zombies or you could stop something
there's fear and you got you know at the
end they could still win
yeah that's my logic you have a real um
emotional
attachment to horror yeah i love it
do you uh almost none it never it was a
genre that never really appealed to me i
can
name the five horror movies i've ever
liked let me guess
the thing the shining i don't know oh
shinee's great exorcist
nah what is it uh freddy krueger
uh nightmare on elm street love that one
love get out
and that might be it wow you know one
day when it's all over i'd love to no
we i want to hang out but it wouldn't be
bad like i want to try and scare you
with the movie that i think is
the scariest movie or one of the
scariest movies and see how you feel
watching it just sitting back with me
you know that's just the thing i don't
um i just don't get scared i i
any time maybe that i maybe be going
down that road i remind myself that it's
a movie which is terrible
i wish i could just enjoy it but i've
never been able to get terrified by a
movie
all right leave me with this leave me
with uh a little uh
michael mcdonald for me
now i know what love in you cause
babe
now we're up to talking divorce
and we won't even marry
[Music]
all my impressions get worse and worse
every year your own wilson's the best
it was it was hey i love you this is
this is a lot of fun man i'm glad we got
to catch up and i and i do miss you and
uh
when this is all over we got to do
something [ __ ] yeah brother can we do
that i don't have a tv show anymore i'm
i'm set i can party wait a minute didn't
you see you had another tv
show or you said i'm in some other tv
shows but i don't have the big the big
one
the time the time killer all right i
like it hey congrats everybody listen
to armchair expert it's uh huge and
awesome and uh he gets amazing guests
and uh you're an amazing guest so thanks
dude thank you i love you rosie love you
too buddy
i really enjoy having dax on the show um
i do and uh he's always honest and i
feel like i could ask him anything he's
one of those guests where you could just
say something and he'll you know
yeah but well you know uh
i always felt you know i i think i get
sometimes annoy we get annoyed with each
other because
i definitely feel like sometimes he's uh
you know he could sort of be that
therapy he's been through so much
therapy i've been through therapy he'll
he'll point things out i mean i know
this about myself you don't have to tell
me
and that's not what and i get defensive
and i'm like that's probably some truth
there
uh it's always an enjoyable time and i
thank him for coming on the podcast
again so that was really nice thank you
all again for listening i hope you
enjoyed and please if you enjoyed dax
please stick around for the next episode
and support the show thank you westwood
one
and all the ladies um agnes and teresa
and catrin
and uh and you know kelly of course
all you guys over at westwood one and
everybody helping lou
and thank you ryan thank you bryce for
making the show better and better
and again at inside you podcast on
instagram and facebook at insideepod on
twitter and all that be good to
yourselves stay strong i'm going to do a
little
patron shout out tell my patrons who
really go above and beyond and uh give
me all the support and love
and again team rogue flask and uh leah
and kristen
thank you for the stage it before i do
that also the online store
inside of you online store we got the
wine glasses and the mugs and the hats
and the
we got horror hats too i have these
awesome i love horror
which is true so and look at that
somebody like they gave me this cup
lee and a bunch of people and mary and
just really nice
oh it's just nice is that nice when
people make you things yeah
it's really nice i don't make people
things no i do i give them things
patron shout out here we go nancy d mary
b leah s trisha app
sarah v little lisa lil lisa you kiko
jill e brian h lauren g you know these
people by now don't you've heard the
names so many times
nico p angelina g robin s jerry w
emily f bobby robert i jason w
stephen jade kristen k amelia o allison
l tom and jess
j lucas m raj emily s cjp
samantha m homs uh b jennifer n
jackie p jackie p stacy l
carly h jennifer s janelle b carrie beat
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
the 273 kimberly e crystal h mike e
marissa and ramirez
beth b santiago m sarah f chadw liam p
rachel c russian r ray a
maya p megan j jennifer c maddie s
tiffany i
almost there guys kendrick f ashley e
margie m thomas t matt w belinda
n benjamin r lisa j kevin v robert s
mike w james r chris h snow r noah k
sean v anusha w ashborn
h and dave h and sheila g
you guys are terrific thank you so much
for listening to the podcast
again and uh let's keep it going man
let's keep having fun
keep tuning in and uh right in you know
i always i have to
read some letters again i haven't done
that in a while yeah so i have to read
some letters i'm gonna have to go to the
hello insideyoupodcast.com and get some
interesting letters
try to make them short if you can that'd
be great i'm not i have add
yeah all right thank you for allowing me
to be inside of each and every one of
you
ryan michael we'll do it again alright
see you next week